non mais tu vois bien ce que je veux
dire c'est quand même hyper bizarre
c'est quoi tu devrait poser la question
à l'est c'est plutôt son domaine ouais
c'est vrai qu'il est plus intelligent
toi je vois pas pourquoi je perds mon
temps
ok les j'ai lu le livre the black swan
de nassim taleb que tu conseiller dans
une de tes vidéos
j'ai été particulièrement intrigués par
le débat entre fat tony et dr john tu
peux me rafraîchir la mémoire c'est quoi
déjà ces débats imagine que je te dise
que cette pièce n'est absolument pas
truqué mais qu'après huit ans et elle
est toujours tombé surface quelle est la
probabilité pour que cette même pièce
tombe sur piles ou 9e lancé ah oui ça me
rappelle quelque chose
tu sais qu'en fait c'est une question
vraiment fascinante et absolument non
trivial d'ailleurs si je me souviens
bien fat tony dr dionne ont des réponses
très différentes
ce qui est intéressant c'est que c'est
un peu des réponses stéréotypées qui
devra peut-être décrire les deux
personnages ça permet de mieux
visualiser le débat ok alors fait tony
c'est un trader de brooklyn très riche
pas si gros que ça c'est juste un surnom
mais c'est vrai que même si tous ces
costumes sont taillés sur mesure en
italie quand ils les portent
on a quand même un peu l'impression que
ça vient de chez celio c'est un bon
vivant il adore manger faire la fête
il a commencé tout en bas de l'échelle
un boulot administratif dans une banque
à wall street
mais il a vite été promu à tony il n'est
pas bardé de diplômes mais il comprend
les gens il sait leur parler il sait
négocier c'est un charmeur et un
embrouilleur c'est le genre de mec qui
peut faire un scandale à l'aéroport
juste histoire de se faire surclasser et
voyager en première quand il est devenu
trader
le succès a été presque immédiat et pour
le moment enfin la chance a toujours été
de son côté alors que dr john c'est un
peu le cliché du bon élève
exactement il a une formation
d'ingénieur avec un doctorat en
ingénierie électrique
il travaille aujourd'hui dans une
compagnie d'assurances il est plutôt
grand mince habile dans le new-jersey
donc pas loin de chez sony mais dans un
appartement beaucoup plus petit et sobre
dr john est en fait un grand calculateur
un maître du temps sa vie est réglée
comme du papier à musique consomme que
ce dont il a besoin et il met un point
d'honneur à toujours choisir le meilleur
rapport qualité prix
il prend son travail très au sérieux
comme une maîtrise les statistiques et
la programmation informatique docteur
john est employé par une société
d'assurances pour calculer et
conseillers l'entreprise dans la gestion
de ces risques financiers et du coup les
réponses des deux personnages
correspondent bien à leur personnalité
selon dr john chaque lancer est
indépendant
les mille ans et précédents n'ont aucune
incidence sur ce qui va se passer
maintenant
il est donc une chance sur deux pour que
la pièce donc sur piles cette fois ci
mepha tony n'est pas du tout d'accord
selon lui ça sent le truc pas clean il
est quasiment sûr que la pièce va encore
tomber surface
bah oui de son point de vue j'ai beau
avoir précisé que la pièce n'était pas
truqué il ne me connaît pas pour lui les
huit lancers précédent qui tombe tout
surface ça montre qu'une seule chose je
suis un gros arnaqueurs et le jeu est
forcément un truc et donc la pièce va
probablement tomber encore surface bon
alors entre l'intuitif anthony et le
calculateur dr john qui a raison et qui
a tort
bon alors je me suis un peu trop de ce
que dit l aide ma la réponse de taleb
tient quand même en 300 pages mais en
gros docteur john se trompent parce
qu'ils attachent une trop grande
importance aux modèles théoriquement
pour une pièce non truquées ya
effectivement une chance sur deux
obtenir pile ou face
les lancers précédents n'ont aucune
importance cela dit un modèle fait
nécessairement des hypothèses
simplificatrices qui seront un jour
violet et rendront le modèle il efficace
par exemple on considère que les
paramètres des différents lancé vont
varier de façon aléatoire
la pièce n'est jamais lancé à la même
hauteur avec la même force et n'est
jamais rattrapé au même niveau mais
peut-être qu'avec beaucoup
d'entraînement les paramètres ne sont
pas si aléatoire que ça en fait quand on
y réfléchit si on répète l'expérience à
l'infini il est très improbable que la
fréquence des piles soit exactement un
demi d'ailleurs il ya des chercheurs qui
ont testé les lancers de pièces et qui
ont découvert qu'une pièce environ 51 %
de chance de tomber sur le même côté que
son côté original au moment du lancer et
si tu t'entraînes et à contrôler le
lancer de ta pièce battue pourrait
peut-être arriver à faire en sorte que
la pièce tombe deux fois sur trois
surfaces
ok donc du coup c'est vraiment fait
tonique a raison et ben non
massy si dr john à tort c'est forcément
que c'est fade tonique a raison en fait
ils ont tous les deux raison et tort
fa tony se trompent parce qu'ils
attachent trop d'importance aux huit
lancers précédent il réagit au bruit
plutôt qu'à la tendance
s'il n'ya pas de tricherie que la pièce
n'est pas truquée et que personne ne
maîtrise des paramètres des lancers
alors huit phases de suite c'est pas si
improbable que ça est en fait une chance
sur 256 pour que ça arrive
huit lancers successifs c'est pas
suffisant pour complètement disqualifié
le modèle wi une chance sur 256 s'est
pas beaucoup mais ça arrive
à peu près tous les 256 cas alors bien
sûr si je prenais une pièce à l'instant
et que devant vos yeux et pour la
première fois je répétais 8 face de
suite
alors là ça serait super étonnant mais
il ne faut pas oublier le biais de
sélection dont on a parlé la dernière
fois il ya de bonnes chances pour qu'on
soit interpellé par ces huit phases de
suite précisément parce que ces huit
faces de suite c'est un cas rare ok mais
alors si j'avais eu 99 fois phase de
suite au lieu de huit
là ça aurait pas pu être le hasard ouais
voilà là ça commence à faire beaucoup
c'est à dire le cas que taleb décrit
dans son bouquin le modèle qui suppose
que le lancer parfaitement 50/50 nous
dit que 99 face de suite bien que
possible ne peut arriver qu'une fois
tous les 6 34 10 puissance 29 essais
ouais alors là le coût des puissances tu
m'excuses des sables absolument rien
dire pour moi tu prends toute la
population de la planète 7 milliards
d'individus
tu les fais lancer des pièces à raison
de 80 19 lancers toutes les dix secondes
pendant 28 millions de milliards
d'années
une fois terminé tu regarde l'ensemble
des essais et tu trouvera sûrement un
seul essai pour lequel on aura obtenu 99
fois face à la suite à dakar à ce moment
là tu t'en vas tu pas un tu dis juste
qu'il ya super super pas beaucoup de
chance on comprend par contre avec lui
lancé seulement ya un doute
en fait le débat entre faty tony dr john
est l'un des grands problèmes récurrents
en machine learning d'un côté na dr john
qui fait de l'odeur fitting que l'on
appelle aussi de l'asu d'interprétation
et de l'autre on a fax tony qui fait de
lover fitting ou de la surinterprétation
en gros ou sous interprète quand on ne
colle pas assez aux données est on sûr
interprète quand on ne colle pas assez
au modèle et c'est encore une fois le
fameux juste milieu qui nous sommes en
effet on parle du dilemme biais variance
ce dilemme prend la forme de l'équation
erreur au carry est égal à bien au carré
plus varens a oui on va parler de cette
équation la wii et pour bien la
comprendre je vais devoir détailler donc
accroche toi imaginons que l'on cherche
à estimer la probabilité pékin a lancé
tombe surface pour cela on va collecter
un jeu de données d qui va typiquement
correspondre aux résultats de huit
lancers et on va ensuite utilisé ces
données pour faire une estimation q2 des
de la probabilité est une des ses notre
estimation p c'est la vraie probabilité
si on ne s'est pas trompé on devrait
voir qu 2d et galp et oui du coup on
peut mesurer la qualité de notre
prédiction par le carré de l'erreur
c'est à dire qu de des mois
le tout au carré mais pour mesurer la
qualité de notre prédiction il faut bien
se rendre compte que les données d qui
sont collectés sont aléatoires en
général elles vont être assez
représentative et nous permettre de bien
apprendre mais parfois on peut avoir un
échantillon étrange ce qui peut nous
conduire à mal à prendre
ah oui genre comme quand on a eu 8 face
à la suite exactement le dilemme biais
variance nous propose alors de mesurer
la qualité de notre prédiction en
prenant de la moyenne des carrés des
erreurs c'est à dire l'espérance depuis
2d - p au carré ou cette espérance est
prise quand des suit la loi de paix et
alors là si du bien tout suivi
c'est ce que tu as appelé le carré de
l'erreur oui c'est ça et bien sûr dans
l'idéal il faudrait que ce carré de
l'erreur soit aussi petit que possible
ok mais du coup est ce qu'on trouve le
biais et la variance dans tout ça le
dilemme biais variance permet
d'identifier deux sources d'erreurs d'un
côté on peut faire des erreurs parce que
notre algorithme donne constamment des
mauvaises prédictions quelles que soient
les valeurs de d c'est ce que l'on
appelle le biais de la prédiction et on
le définit comme l'écart entre la
moyenne des prédictions est la vraie
valeur de paix comme cherché à estimer
dans notre cas le biais donc l'espérance
de q2 des moins la valeur de paix ok
donc ça c'est le biais au carré dans ton
équation oui et de l'autre côté on peut
faire des erreurs parce que d'un jeu de
donner à l'autre notre algorithme
apprend tout et son contraire
et du coup forcément pour au moins
certains jeux de données d il fait des
erreurs
c'est ce que l'on appelle la variance de
l'apprentissage il est égal à la
variance de q2 des camps d essuie la loi
imposée par la vraie probabilité paix et
sas accroissons à cette grosse formule
que voici qui est donc formellement de
l'espérance du carré de l'écart à la
moyenne donc là je suis chaud on retombe
sur l'équation erreur car il ya le biais
carré plus variance et on a deux sources
d'erreurs le biais mon algues ont fait
de la merde parce qu'il n'est pas assez
précis la variance mont elgon fait de la
merde parce que certains jeux de données
sont bizarres et du coup on apprend mal
exactement et ces deux sources d'erreurs
sont parfaitement illustré par nos deux
personnages le problème de dr jones et
le biais et celui de fat tony c'est la
variance est ce qu'on pourrait pas avoir
un petit exemple numérique juste pour
être sûr ok imaginons que je me suis
entraîné toute ma vie si bien que
maintenant j'arrive à lancer la pièce
pour qu'elle tombe surface avec
probabilité deux tiers ici aussi dr john
va se planter dans sa prédiction
oui et on peut quantifier à quel point
il se plante on a vu que sa prédiction
était toujours un demi quelles que
soient les données observées ainsi pour
dr john q est toujours égal à 1,2 me
mais du coup le biais des dr john est
égal à l'espérance de q - paix ou qu est
égal à 1,2 me et paix est égale à deux
tiers si vous fait un demi - deux tiers
qui est égal à - 1 6e en revanche la
prédiction de dr john ne souffre
d'aucune variance puisque sa prédiction
ne varie pas avec les données d du coup
la variance de dr john est égal à zéro
en utilisant maintenant le théorème bien
variance on voit que l'erreur au carré
de dr clown est égal à moins d'un
sixième au carré + 0
ce qui nous fait un 36e et donc son
erreur et la racine carrée 2-1 36e qui
est égal à 1 6e autrement dit la
prédiction de dr john sera typiquement
une distance de 0,28 cent soixante-sept
de la vraie valeur de pays et ça c'est
mal pour le savoir on va le comparer à
l'erreur de facto ni la prédiction de
tony elle va dépendre des résultats des
lancers supposons que je vous montre 8,2
me lancer alors le nombre des deux fois
que la ps va tomber surface reste un
nombre aléatoire mais si j'ai deux
chances sur trois de tomber surface
alors des as plus de chances d'être
proche de 8 que 2 0 en fait des va
suivre une loi binomiale de paramètres
huit le nombre de lancers et deux tiers
la probabilité de tomber surface
autrement dit on à l'équation de la loi
binomiale la probabilité que des gars là
qu'a été gala cas parmi n p puissance
qu'à 1 - p puissances ennemies cas si je
remplace par des valeurs numériques ça
me fait qu'à puissance 8 x 2 puissance
qu'à diviser par trois patients suite
bon ça fait une grosse équation nous on
peut voir les valeurs numériques
voilà un graphique qui reprend les
probabilités de voir plusieurs fois face
à paraître après huit lancés par exemple
il ya 3,9 pour cent de chance de n'avoir
que des faces mais seulement 0,015 % de
chance de n'avoir que des piles en gros
dés qu'on va avoir des données d qui
vont illustrer des cars théoriquement
rares facto n'y va avoir tendance à
faire une mauvaise estimation de paix en
effet pour formaliser tout ça supposons
que fat stone y colle parfaitement aux
données empiriques
autrement dit supposons qu'ils prédisent
que la probabilité de phase soit égal à
la fréquence empirique des faces du coup
la prédiction de file tony est qu 2d est
égal à des / n l'avantagent de cela
c'est qu'en moyenne fait toni va prédire
espérances de q2 des qui est égal à
l'espérance de dédit
et par huit ça comme l'espérance d'une
soi mais la somme des expériences ça
nous fait parfois m / rennes qui est
égal ap on dit que la prédiction de tony
elles n'ont guère aisée puisque le biais
de tony est égal à l'espérance de sa
prédiction - la valeur de paix et ça
c'est égal à zéro et ça c'est cool
du coup ça montre que facto niemeier non
non pas forcément parce que le problème
de fat tony c'est la variance de sa
prédiction 7 variance est égale à la
variance 2d / l et ça après quelques
calculs cela ne fait p x 1 monte / l
quand on remplace n par huit et paix par
deux tiers n'obtient alors variance de
tony est égal à 2/9 / 8 et ça c'est égal
à 1 36e
du coup l'erreur de tony qui est égale à
la racine carrée du bien au carré plus
la variance c'est la racine carrée 2 0 +
1 sur 36 qui est égal à 1 6e
me wade comme dr john cox j'ai fait
exprès de prendre ces chiffres
au final face tony et dr john font aussi
bien l'un que l'autre
ok j'ai rien compris aux calculs mais je
pense comprendre le problème dr john est
complètement rigide il veut voir que le
modèle et du coup sabia son analyse
d'un autre côté fatto ni il veut voir
que les données donc qui peut se mettre
après dire tout et n'importe quoi en
fonction de ce qu'ils observent
exactement et dans notre cas les deux
problèmes sont aussi graves
l'un que l'autre mais du coup est ce
qu'on peut faire mieux que docteur john
et facto ni week typiquement faudra
quelque chose d'intermédiaire entre la
rigidité du dr john et la
surinterprétation de facto ni il faudra
un estimateur à la fois légèrement
biaisé et légèrement variant et ça c'est
le cas par exemple de la loi de
succession de la place là il y aurait
beaucoup de choses à dire sur le sujet
notamment parce qu'elle a des fondements
assez bayésiens un bail et quoi à 6 pas
le temps d'expliquer aujourd'hui bon
mais sinon c'est toi de la place c'est
quoi la loi de succession de la place
dit alors de prédire q2 des est égale 1
des puces 1 / une puce de et l'erreur de
la place sera alors de 0,37
ce qui est mieux que les 0 160 7 de dr
john et fat sony mine de rien ça fait
quand même 20% de mieux et ça peut faire
d énormes différencie des milliards sont
en jeu
ah ouais c'est cool et du coup pourquoi
on n'utilise pas tout le temps la loi de
la place ba pour commencer parce que
c'est pas la prédiction
optimal et oui la prédiction optimale
ces études est égal ap bah oui tout
bêtement on a alors bière est égal à
variance est égal à erreur est égal à
zéro
mais bien sûr toute la difficulté du
dilemme bien variance c'est qu'on ne
connaît pas et pire parce que l'on ne
connaît pas paix y compris après coup il
était impossible non seulement de
prédire la performance d'une prédiction
mais il est aussi très compliqué de
juger la performance d'une prédiction y
compris après coup mais alors du coup je
suis plus sûr de rien a en fait c'est
même pire encore mais accroche toi ça va
être
mais tu as le truc compliqué c'est que
rien qu en invoquant le dilemme biais
variance on est déjà en train
d'introduire un biais de notre façon de
penser puisque les dilemmes bien
variance va typiquement présupposés qui
lie à une variable paix à connaître qui
sera une sorte de vérité fondamentale
sauf que ce n'est pas clair que
l'existence de cette vérité fondamentale
soit vrai a il y aura tellement plus à
dire mais je vais m'arrêter là pour
aujourd'hui
alors récapitulons le problème dont on
vient de parler c'est celui de la
généralisation à partir d'exemples qui
est un problème classique non seulement
en finance et en statistiques mais aussi
en machine learning en particulier c'est
un problème à la fois pour nous autres
humains et pour les intelligences
artificielles
on a vu que les erreurs dues à la
généralisation se décompose en deux
types d'erreurs d'un côté le biais et de
l'autre la variance le bien c'est
lorsque notre modèle d'apprentissage est
trop rigide et ne s'adaptent pas
suffisamment aux données c'est ce qui
arrive quand on fait trop confiance à
certains modèles
on appelle ça l'honneur fille team ou la
soupe d'interprétation al'inverse la
variance c'est lorsque l'on sort
beaucoup trop du cadre des modèles et
que l'on cherche trop à coller aux
données observées c'est typiquement ce
qui se passe quand on observe le cours
de bourse toutes les 5 minutes et qu'on
réagit assez moindre fluctuation alors
qu'on a choisi une stratégie
d'investissement sur le long terme
on appelle ça lover phishing ou la
surinterprétation le problème c'est que
diminuer le biais conduit souvent
augmenter la variance et vice versa faut
donc trouver un juste milieu entre ces
deux extrêmes tout en sachant que la
mesure du billet et la variance implique
la connaissance d'une loi paix qu'on
cherche justement à prendre donc qu'on
ne connaît pas et dont on n'est même pas
sûr qu'elle existe bref analyser des
données que ce soit pour une machine ou
pour un humain c'est pas simple
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette
collaboration avec gilles de la chaîne
eurêka si vous connaissez pas allez voir
c'est absolument génial celui qui fait
ce que j'adore avec les vidéos de gilles
c'est que à chaque fois il précise très
bien la limite des modèles qui
considèrent et l'étendue de l'ignorance
que ça sous entend généralement après
une vidéo d'oreca on comprend beaucoup
mieux comment les choses fonctionnent
mais on comprend aussi et surtout
beaucoup mieux ce que l'on ne peut pas
comprendre étant donné l'état actuel des
connaissances notamment en finance et en
économie voilà je pense que ça réflexe
excellent qui à oreca et que devra avoir
peut-être plus de youtuber savoir
précisé le fait qu' il ya plein de
choses qu'on ne sait pas et insisté sur
l'étendue de notre ignorance est en tout
cas j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
permis de sentir à quel point c'était
compliqué d'avoir une réponse au final
une question si simple car lens et de
pièces et que c'est ouvert mais
d'imaginer que en pratiquant finance
tout est beaucoup plus compliquée encore
dernière fois que j'avais proposé de
participer à un sondage où j'avais eu
pose exactement le problème de la pièce
alors j'avais fait à la fois des
statistiques sur google forme également
sur youtube
et voici les résultats c'est à peu près
les mêmes dans les deux cas en gros 80%
d'entre vous sont dr john sellar vous
fait confiance encore en modèle il dit
que la pièce est non seulement nous
truqué mais également non biaisée au
moment du lancer et donc que la
probabilité d'un face reste 0.5 y en a
aussi parmi vous qui sont plus fat tony
c'est ce qu'ils ont à me tout à droite
qui correspond à dire que la probité 1
face au 9e lancé est égal à 1
j'aurais tendance à dire que ces deux
réponses 05 l'oim sont pas très bonnes
parce que d'une certaine manière on
s'attend à quelque chose qui est plutôt
entre les deux en tout cas le dilemme
biais variance nous pousse à penser
quelque chose qui est entre les deux et
y en a effectivement 7% parmi nous qui
ont peut-être senti venir ce problème du
dilemme biais variance et qui ont mis
entre 0,5 et 1
jeudi on a aussi quelques uns parmi vos
qui ont mis tout à gauche 0 1 0
je sais pas si c'est parce que vous avez
mal lu les noms séjour a tendance à dire
que ce qui est vraiment à gauche là
c'est vraiment pas une
réponse en soutien ça ne paraît pas très
pertinent bon après entre 0,5 et 1
quelle est la bonne réponse alors là je
crois vraiment disserter mais pendant
des heures et des heures à écrire tout
un livre sur le sujet c'est vraiment je
pense une question fondamentale est
absolument fascinante que de déterminer
quelle est la probabilité qu'il faudrait
assignés à ce 9e face dans cette suite
de lancer il y aurait énormément de
choses à dire notamment les eaux
gerville réache alias paradoxe il écrit
notamment ce livre de paradoxes
renversant en probabilité dans lequel il
parle notamment d'une publication de
d'alembert
c'est une vidéo qui a fait à ce sujet
qui est d'une certaine manière je pense
une meilleure réponse encore que la loi
de succession de la place mais pour vous
expliquer pourquoi il faudrait que je
rentre dans les détails du mécanisme
heureusement ça prendrait un peu pas mal
de temps sinon la fin on a surtout parlé
du biais de la surinterprétation et en
particulier les vues composition
bidouiller statistiques pour faire dire
à peu près tout et n'importe quoi c'est
ici que comme le roi des singes ça
correspond aux proverbes motion qui est
absolument fondamental qu'il faut
retenir
qui dit que si on torture les chiffres
il vous avons ce que vous voulez il ya
aussi cette fameuse citation attribuée à
benjamin disraeli qui dit qu il existe
trois types de mensonges les mensonges
les mensonges maudit et les statistiques
et en effet quand on parle de sacy qu'il
faut faire vraiment très très gaffe
surtout si lui un biais de sélection de
la statistique en question et ça en
pratique quand vous lisez une
statistique est en 11e un journal ce que
vous voulez ce sera forcément une
statistique choisi par l'auteur de
l'article
et c'est souvent pour que ça étant le
sens de son message adrien le x demande
aussi du coup ça veut dire qu'il ne faut
pas faire confiance aux statistiques en
tout cas faut pas faire confiance
aveuglément en tout cas aux statistiques
qui vous sont rapportés par quelqu'un
qui a un parti pris et qui a choisi
cette statistique pour défendre son
parti pris cependant cette méfiance
envers les statistiques ne veut pas dire
qu'il faut accepter les autres méthodes
non statistique fait bien souvent quand
on utilise autre chose que statistiques
c'est encore plus facile d'avoir tout un
argumentaire qui va défendre telle ou
telle position
en fait de façon plus générale ce qui
est important de voir à travers le biais
de la surinterprétation c'est que ce
biais n'est pas du tout spécifique à
l'analyse de données ou aux statistiques
en tout cas avec des chiffres classique
de façon plus générale ce biais de sur
interprétations il intervient à tous
moments qui font le gros problème des
anecdotes c'est que lorsqu'on vous
raconte
l'anecdote elle soit ont été
sélectionnés parmi tout un ensemble
d'anecdotes imaginables pour pouvoir
défendre une position plutôt qu'une
autre
le biais de surinterprétation
correspondra à donner trop d'importance
à cette anecdote alors que ces anecdotes
s'explique généralement très bien par le
hasard et le fait qu'il y ait un biais
de sélection qui a sélectionné les cales
plus étrange parmi toutes les anecdotes
qui ont eu lieu
j'insiste encore sur ça parce que je
pense que ce biais de la
surinterprétation c'est un énorme
problème dont beaucoup d'analystes et
malheureusement à l'école les très peu
enseignée voir j'ai bien peur qu'à
l'école bien souvent on favorise le la
surinterprétation de beaucoup de choses
et notamment je me souviens de pas mal
de cours de français où j'avais
l'impression qu'on faisait quand même
dire pas mal de choses à des textes que
ces textes ne voulait pas forcément dire
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya quand même
pas mal de travail de sur
interprétations au moment de l'analyse
de texte en tout cas en cours de
français en tout cas c'est mon
impression est à la limite c'est pas
tant le prenne le problème c'est surtout
que nous encourager à faire ce travail
de sur interprétations sans jamais nous
parler des dangers de la
surinterprétation j'ai quand même pas
mal l'impression qu'il ya pas mal de
cours à l'école ou en fait on apprend à
faire de la surinterprétation sans
jamais nous signaler le danger de la
surinterprétation ce qui pourrait amener
du coup l'éducation à nous conduire à
surinterpréter tout plein de choses et
ça pourrait peut-être à être l'une des
explications au fait que la croyances au
paranormal soit en fait corrélée avec le
niveau d'études sont les jo qui ont fait
plus d'études croit plus au paranormal
en tout cas c'est ce qu'affirme henry
broc dans cette interview sur la tronche
en biais du coup moi je serais vraiment
d'avis qu'en cours de français notamment
on étudie ce biais de surinterprétation
par exemple en lisant des textes
modernes par exemple des articles de
journaux et on essayait de comprendre
qu'elle était par exemple les intentions
de l'auteur et quels sont les billets de
surinterprétation qu'a pu faire un
auteur d'un article de journal
plutôt que d'être dans une certaine
posture de l'admiration des auteurs de
textes ça serait bien d'avoir un regard
assez critique sur les auteurs des
textes de façon assez générale je pense
bon voilà je sens que je me tapais une
vague de critiques de professeur de
français
mais bon je pense que c'est vraiment un
débat à avoir parce que je pense que les
conséquences de surinterprétation sont
absolument dramatiques
aujourd'hui le semble qu'il s'agit d'une
des principales causes
cette bipolarisation qu'on peut avoir
immergé sûrement sur le web avec les
fils turbulents et tout ça est
malheureusement il ya très très peu
d'éducation aux dangers de la
surinterprétation plutôt aux gones de
shia sbaï 42 et rémy père pour remarquer
que le biais de sélection des données
qui vont être ensuite analysées par les
algorithmes est un énorme problème de
société aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs j'ai
envie de dire que c'est vraiment pas
spécifique aux algorithmes typiquement
si les données sont biaisées et objets
observe une certaine différence entre
une certaine classe d'individus une
autre classe d'individus dans les
performances de tel ou tel truc on
pourra avoir un algorithme qui apprend
du coup quelque chose qu'on pourrait
qualifier de racisme tout cas un organe
algorithme qui distingue les gens en
fonction par exemple de leur apparence
physique et bien cette problématique est
vraiment devenu un problème de recherche
en tant que tel de savoir qu'est ce
qu'on veut vraiment que les algorithmes
face à ce qu'on veut des alcools qui
ignorent ce genre de bien vous voyez que
ces questions en fait sont très très
très publiées elles sont en fait pas du
tout spécifique aux machines comme
apparemment gilles dowek semble avoir
dit dans une conférence les humains à
travers notamment le biais de sur
interprétations sont aussi victimes de
ce genre de guerre voire plus encore que
les machines sauf que on a tendance à
plus tolérer le racisme par les humains
que le racisme par les machines
bref comme le dit rémi père est saisie
d'une grande question philosophique et
poétique à laquelle vous n'aurez pas
encore de réponse satisfaisante tout cas
pas de réponse qui fasse consensus
rafael cruz co demande s'il s'agissait
vraiment d'une question dover fitting la
vidéo précédente parce que souvent lover
fitting on la prend en tout cas dans les
cours de machine learning comme étant
dans le cadre typiquement de
l'apprentissage superviser ou lorsqu'on
cherche à trop à coller aux données on a
du coup une fonction qui se généralise
mal à dézoner qu'on n'a pas encore
observé on en reparlera d'ailleurs la
semaine prochaine en effet su permis
d'extraire la définition de l'odeur
fitting de ce cadre formel
visuel on voit en quoi parce que je
pense que le problème de l'eau d'heure
fitting et de la surinterprétation est
un problème beaucoup plus générale que
ce simple cadre de l'apprentissage
superviser il me semble que on peut
vraiment dire que le problème de façon
très générale c'est d'interpréter des
trucs des fluctuations statistiques
comme ayant un sens qui doit être
expliqué et être exploitée pour faire
des prédictions et le truc c'est que
pour pouvoir expliquer ces fluctuations
statistiques il faut à ce moment là à
faire intervenir des modèles beaucoup
plus sophistiqué c'est sont généralement
ces règles trop sophistiqué qui se
généralise mal et des données n'ont
observé
et si on considère que leur footing
c'est ça c'est considérer des modèles
trop sophistiqué pour l'expliquer en
fait ce qui n'est que du hasard
eh bien on est vraiment dans le cadre de
loire fitting notamment dans le cas de
spéculation puisque à ce moment là on a
des milliers de jeux de données donc
d'élite et des dizaines de milliers de
données mais le nombre de corrélation
qu'on va étudier est en fait très très
très grande de l'ordre du million du
coup en fait on a beaucoup plus de
paramètres d'une certaine manière que
l'on utilise que de données et de façon
très générale quand on a beaucoup plus
de paramètres que de donner on risque
fort d'utiliser ces paramètres
supplémentaires pour pouvoir interpréter
des trucs qui en fait ne sont que du
hasard
la grosse difficulté de lover fitting
notamment dans le cas de spiros
connection c'est que lorsqu'on ne donne
que la corrélation qui est significative
on a l'impression qu'on n'a pas
considéré toutes les corrélations qui
ont été étudiées par le modèle ces mêmes
problèmes en fait qu'on a dans le cadre
d'apprentissage superviser c'est le fait
d'avoir choisi une règle qui semble bien
expliqué et donnait alors qu'en fait il
y avait beaucoup de règles qui
expliquait également assez bien les
données et en particulier si on
changeait un tout petit peu les données
alors on sélectionnerait d'autres
modèles ou d'autres corrélation dans le
cas d'espèce corrélation et du coup on
augmenterait énormément la variance de
notre apprentissage et de nos
prédictions
bref tout ça pour dire que je pense que
le problème de la surinterprétation
c'est absolument pas limité à un cadre
formel on a l'habitude d'étudier en
machine learning
c'est vraiment un problème beaucoup plus
fondamentale que cela et qu'il faut
absolument que l'on soit conscient de ce
problème notamment dans la vie courante
où on exposer a énormément
d'informations qui ont été sélectionnés
à partir de données très bruitée en
particulier la conséquence très
importante à avoir en tête de tout ça
c'est la conclusion qui est donnée par
linux citrix à savoir le fait que à
cause du biais de la surinterprétation
et internes
ce biais de sélection de données qui ont
l'air significative une fois qu'on les a
sélectionnés qu'on les a sortis du coup
du contexte d'apprentissage ou de façon
plus générale c'est le fait que deux
personnes qui sont en fait quasiment
d'accord initialement mais qui vont
légèrement penché d'un côté légèrement
de l'autre vont finir par être exposé
assez rapidement des données qui vont
uniquement aller dans leur sens et du
coup vont finir par diverger du coup
deux personnes qui sont parfaitement
intelligente parfaitement rationnel tout
ce que vous voulez peuvent finir si
elles sont victimes du biais de la
surinterprétation par avoir des avis
complètement divergents je pense que ce
phénomène est absolument crucial à
comprendre dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'ils avaient mais cette vidéo
la prochaine fois on va continuer à
parler de lover fitting et on va
notamment se poser la question de
comment lutter optimalement contre cette
horreur fitting contre launder fitting
également comment essayer de trouver le
fitting optimale comme on l'appelle tout
vous invite à y réfléchir de vous-même
d'ici là si vous avez aimé cet épisode
spécial de l'ikea le commentaire de
partage et pensez à vous abonner pour
autant les futurs épisodes merci au type
erp l'ordre et j'espère que vous serez
là la prochaine fois tous ces problèmes
viennent complexifier l'argumentation de
ricardo et s'il est certain qu'un modèle
économique doit simplifier les choses
tous les économistes ne sont pas
d'accord sur les variables que l'on peut
considérer comme négligeable et qui
peuvent effectivement être retirés des
équations